can I just read you the menu of shady
Gators would you guys be interested in
that yeah be very interested tell me all
the variations of tater tots you mean
Gator bites or ultimate tater tots or
loaded loaded tots um for
[Music]
me all right we're live uh we have got
Sam Ratner by the way Sean I I don't
know Sam that well I think you think
that I know him
well yeah because I don't know him so
I'm like how' this guy get here he's uh
he's here because Ari talked to her talk
to him on the phone we do these pre-
calls and same I got to say like out of
uh I don't know every 10 pre- calls we
do with people that we don't know eight
out of 10 are are kind of like a hey
probably not a good fit for the Pod she
talked to you and she was like you gotta
have this guy on so I don't even know
what you did but you did something and
you have some kind of story or energy or
ideas that that she liked yeah basically
what what I know about you is by the way
you're like shockingly young how old are
you 27 26 yeah I just turned 27 and what
I know about you is you had this company
that was a sports betting site you sold
it for around $40 million to fubo TV
like I think before it even launched but
you've also done all these other strange
things like I think you bought did you
buy a riverbat casino or a river boat
like You' bought a bunch like you're
into a lot of really strange things and
for such a young person you've done like
a lot of odd I mean just the fact that
you've done a start that you sold for a
lot of money that's already impressive
but even amongst the impressive people
you've done a a lot of like strange and
unique things right all right so let's
start with that you were you drop out of
college and you start a company that you
end up selling for can you say how much
you sold for yeah it was 40 million okay
so you drop out of college you build a
company you sell it for 40 million at
that time you must have been pretty
young how old were you when you sold
23 okay great so 18 to 23 is uh what was
what was the idea and how did you make
that
happen uh so I had gone I was actually
at the University of Missouri for a year
nice missou so I was I was at mizou uh
enjoyed my time there was not for me
though uh always wanted to kind of start
a company uh when I dropped out I didn't
really have the exact plan yet uh but I
did always play a lot of online poker I
was very active I was the kid with 12
monitors uh playing online poker in the
dorm rooms so I kind of knew the
community a lot um and you know started
hearing whispers of them legalizing you
know gaming National here in the United
States you know lifting the federal ban
if you would and I thought the market
would evolve shouldn't evolve much
differently than it does overseas where
it's very part of the culture you can
bet when you're 18 sometimes 16 you're
betting you know at the Arsenal game
inside the stadium but here there was
like a stigma to it you know if grandma
says she buys a lottery ticket you know
uh you're like you don't think anything
but if she says she took the bear spread
you're like ah Grandma what the hell are
you doing so um I thought if that would
be the case I just sat down and
essentially just rote out for hours how
I thought the market would evolve and my
conclusion was that um there will be
early players you'll have DraftKings and
FanDuel they have you know audiences and
fantasy but that it really would end up
being dominated by either the brick and
mortar Casino companies or the media
companies which is now just playing out
with ESPN and stuff in to dat all the
technology had been built overseas
because it's been around for 50 years
but it was like built in the early 2000s
where you had like these desktop
applications to place a bet and then to
get to Mobile they just like compressed
it into a mobile experience they didn't
like rebuild it they didn't rebuild it
native iOS it didn't have any good API
functionality to have ticketing and
Merchandising and these other things so
I said what if we just what if I just
rebuilt all that and then called these
big companies and said hey uh don't
white label this garbage from Sweden um
you know and pay some huge rev share
what if we just do a deal can you can
you pause that for a second yeah so
you're you're describing what sounds
like pretty sophisticated process you're
like I heard you know that there's this
inflection that there maybe it was going
to get legalized so I started thinking
ahead of that and then instead of just
jumping right in with my two Dumb
Friends and starting to build a product
I thought I wrote down how I thought the
market would evolve and then I realized
that my good go to market would be to
kind of undercut these rev share
competitors with a mobile first product
on the platform dude you're like 18 19
years old at this time you know I
couldn't figure out how my night was
going to evolve let alone how how a
market was going to evolve like was this
your first rodeo and why why were you so
good at it at that time so in high
school I ran a snow removal business um
which natural pivot natural pivot uh and
so I had been you could call it in
business in a very rudimentary way we
were plowing driveways um but we had
hundreds of houses I kind of knew how to
build a business and what I realized
although I learned a ton I'm like 15 I'm
learning what insurance is because some
woman slipped on salt I'm learning how
to you know Finance you know trucks to
get plows like so I kind of had this
business sense and by the way when
you're talking about plowing you're not
talking about shoveling you just said
financing trucks yeah like the plows you
put on the front of trucks got it okay
yeah so you were sophisticated you're
going door too to get these customers
for yourn business how it was me and uh
uh a good friend of mine Ilia who's now
David Do's right-hand guy Ilia
federovich we went to high school
together I went to Vernon Hills which is
where they went so illy and I built the
snow removal business and we'd be like
at used car lots negotiating for
essentially but what I learned from how
much were you making back then 15 16
years old I think we did like 50 60
grand for the winner or something like
that so and I couldn't drive that was a
big problem ILO only had his permit I
didn't have a license so we couldn't
really get anywhere there was no Uber or
at least we didn't have debit cards so
like we'd like walk to like mundeline
which is like the neighboring town to
like go look at the plows it was
complicated but what I learned from that
is you could scale that business um and
actually do really well from a cash flow
perspective because cander most people
don't want to be in that business or
they're like 60 years old and they've
been just driving the same truck for the
same couple commercial Lots but what I
learned is there's no value it can't it
can't scale that well that large and I
was just always interested in like how
big can I make something and I had that
itch to do that so then I thought well
if it's easy there can't be any value in
it if anyone could just get into it well
then there's inherently zero value
longterm like big if you want to build
billion dollar business
so when I thought gambling could be big
it would have been very easy to be like
oh we're going to have a fantasy site
that is slightly different and you can
pay to play and it also includes Nascar
or something and like all those things
just to me it's like eh how does that
get to 500 million in Revenue I don't
see it I'm not interested so I knew I
had to really sit down and think how
will the market evolve and then I
literally just looked at what are the P
of this pieces of this Evolution that
because it's such a headache or Capital
intensive no one will ever want to touch
and then because of that it should
actually end up being slightly less
Capital intensive because no one wants
to do it and then you have value it was
my thought
essentially our software is the worst
have you heard of HubSpot see most crms
are a cobble together mess but HubSpot
is easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
and when you dropped out was that a easy
decision for you to go do this gambling
company was it hard and basically how
did you live cuz I always wonder this
when people drop out of college you're
kind of college is a very it's a bubble
that's like yeah here's your bed here's
the bathroom here's the library you know
these are this is your place and then
when you drop out you're like out of the
system you're neither at home nor are
you in school so what was uh it was
definitely uh uh my parents were not
thrilled as you can imagine um uh and
when you go home it's it's like when you
grow up uh you're my son I love you and
then when you turn 18 you're like that
guy in the house you're like you're like
what are you still doing here uh so uh I
I went home and lived with my mom um
although I essentially I went to
Starbucks every morning and worked until
from whenever they open 5 or 6 a.m.
until they closed at 7 and then I'd go
to Lifetime Fitness and there were no
yoga classes after 8 so I would work in
the yoga studio upstairs at Lifetime and
they had free coffee free all that stuff
so I kind of had like an office and it
kind of got to the point where I started
leaving my stuff as like a setup in the
corner and I think a lot of I think the
instructors thought like oh that's
someone else's class and it was just
like my laptop and monitor and computer
so I worked out a lifetime for like
three like a year uh and it was cheap
because uh you know lifetime whatever I
was under the 28 age so I'm playing like
the reduced thing um and I would just
kind of work all day so I lived at my
mom how did you fund how did you fund
the company at that stage uh come on
Sean credit cards baby uh I essentially
what happened to that snowplow money oh
yeah uh we had some cash from that but
uh essentially like I knew I needed I
knew you literally you kind of have two
options if you don't have tons and tons
of cash saved you essentially you can
work a part-time job um uh I was
unwilling to do anything but spend every
waking moment on the business so I
didn't want to do that and so I kind of
just went open to credit cards and I've
always been a zero backup plan guy I
perfect I purposely failed every final
before dropping out so going back was
not an option because I'd be going back
at like 23 years old as a freshman so
I'm always a put it all on the line and
you will figure it out kind of guy and
uh purposely failed de finals yeah
that's that's what I that's what I say
too so so I came home when I dropped out
I came home you know when like you come
home a little early and it's like you're
surprising your parents and you're like
oh like did you finish early I came home
early enough where it was kind of too
early for them to believe that I had
finished finals so what that essentially
meant is I didn't show up to the finals
and I got zeros on all the finals so
going back was now out of the question
which removed the debate with my parents
because they kind of said well he can't
really go back you ended up selling did
you sell the company I was looking at
the the site on web archive did you sold
the company before it even launched
right yeah like 18 months is that right
yeah yeah about all right so
who who contacted you how did they even
know that you were up for up for grab so
what we had was essentially every
component to a gambling platform that
you could want so we were an authorized
gaming operator of the NBA Major League
Baseball I just willed my way into
convincing the leagues to do a deal with
me um candidly I think they thought I
was like kind of crazy and kind of cool
and they're not used to cool and crazy
they're used to like Disney so they were
like okay we'll do the deal with you so
it was like well explain that I would
think if if a 19-year-old's like yeah
I'm going to go become an authorized
gaming uh you know operator for the NBA
I'd be like yeah it's not really going
to happen man so what's what's your
other plan so uh how did you do that
yeah they would like offer you an
internship instead yeah uh uh we had a
couple things we at that time we did
raise a little bit of capital and it was
from some Venture funds in sports media
and entertainment that the leagues knew
very well so they were like okay uh this
kid called us 6 months ago he sounds
kind of crazy but now it seems like
there's this article out um the people
that invested in them um 76 Capital also
invested in a bunch of other companies
we have deals with so there's some
significance there um we also they were
very familiar with our lawyers because
our lawyers represent ESPN and a lot of
other people so you kind of just have to
put the pieces in place that kind of
give them some gut feel to they're not
he's not just crazy he's crazy and he
has some people that we know and so at
the time it was like DraftKings FanDuel
MGM bar stool and then like us
and and the league was also like a
little careful like can we like uh we'll
do this with you just don't tell anyone
right now and we don't really want to
put out an article but we kind of want
to do the deal we think the platform's
cool so we kind of had all these assets
we were an authorized gaming operator of
those leagues we had Market access which
I can get into which is the licenses we
were through compliance in mostly all
legal states now back then it was 17
States or so um now it's 35 Plus I think
um and at the time if you wanted to be
in the gaming business uh you have to go
through regular compliance most public
Boards of directors have no interest in
going through a regulatory process they
have to disclose their financials and
all these things so uh and they also
didn't know the business enough um you
know you can be a big public company but
if you want to have a book in Jersey you
have to go down to Atlantic City and sit
in an old room with regulators and
lawyers and convince them as to why they
should give you the license um and so it
was just like this old school process uh
that they were unwilling to go through
and we kind of spent the money and went
through the pain of building the
platform getting it through compliance
getting the license licenses getting the
deals and we knew that what we really
wanted was an existing audience in
sports even if we went and raised $100
million I think DraftKings at the time
spent $100 million on corporate travel a
year so $100 million wasn't going to
move the needle for us to go to market
without any users so we started talking
about a joint venture with a handful of
companies uh and at the time fubo TV had
just gone public they put out a proxy
they wanted to be in the gaming business
and my phone rang um and it was fubo TV
and they wanted to talk about a deal so
um which and so they they they bought
you for I think I I read the SEC filing
like just about close to 40 million what
uh what' you do with the money uh I have
it what do you mean well I mean that's a
that's that's a lot of money for anyone
to get particularly for 23 24 year old
uh what you invested in um I'm mostly in
the market and then I have these
small random crazy Investments that I
feel really good about um but I'm mostly
in the market I'm pretty long here's why
I'm long the market if I want to do
other things with the money I'll simply
take a loan against my portfolio and
then take the risk if you sell the stock
now you have a taxable event you get
less than like if you wanted to put a
million bucks into something you can
either sell a million dollars and have
some huge taxable event and a headache
to deal with with paperwork uh and then
you invest and then if it goes to zero
you're screwed or you take a line of
credit against your portfolio say in the
index fund like the Spy um and if I need
a million I'll take a line of credit
they keep a million two is collateral
and then I get to take my million dollar
shot anyways and if it doesn't work out
uh all I got to do is wait and in eight
years I'll have the money back because
the stock would have doubled anyways um
you know given what the interest rates
are pretty low when you take a loan
against like that so I have most all my
money for the most part in the market so
yeah I was down like during Co like
millions and millions and millions of
dollars but like if you're never selling
then it just doesn't really matter and
if you don't need it like I kept what I
needed in cash like whatever but other
than that I'm pretty in the
market but that's where your story gets
kind of kind of interesting so like all
right selling for that amount of money
at the age of 23 pre-launch that's
that's you know 1% the 1% that's pretty
wild but I read that you know when Ari
talked to you and and I read in our
notes I read that you bought this
riverbat what the hell is that and
that's one of your crazy Investments and
you also were looking at vending machine
businesses this is wild to me that you
would do this okay so uh when you're in
the online gaming business everyone
who's in it for the most part is like
the old Trump gaming people All The
Regulators are the same one time we got
a document and they had Still They sent
us the wrong copy because my partner
Scott bera's name was when he was
president of trump so they sent us a
trump entertainment Resorts form like
The Regulators never change so while the
business is techy you could call it the
industry is not so everyone you meet is
like has been in this casino business
for 50 years and I stumbled into this
Riverboat because um to get a license uh
unlike a cannabis license where you can
just apply as a dispensary you have to
get what's called Market access and the
you are subleasing the licenses from the
ones that have them and the only people
that have them are the brick and mortar
properties it's kind of like if you it's
weird if you wanted a grocery store
imagine if you had the suas from Whole
Foods like a license that they have the
entry the reason that's the case is
because uh you know we took land from
Native Americans we allowed them to have
casinos on reservation property uh then
all of a sudden 2018 the government goes
we'll just legalize online gambling well
then they were like well no one's going
to come to our properties anymore CU
they can just log on DraftKings and you
just screwed us so you should give us
the license and then we'll sublease it
to them so they did that and then MGM
and Cesar and everyone went crazy
because they're like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa we're the biggest tax revenue
drivers in the country besides oil so if
the if the tribes are getting them then
we get them fast forward everyone got
them riverboats counted as properties
brick and mortar properties and before
landbased gaming in the early 90s
everything was on the water because it
was illegal and it started in the early
40s and 50s because all the trade
happened up and down the Mississippi
candidly mostly through St Louis and
people would just like truckers pull
over on the highway people would pull
over their vessels and they'd have
makeshift card games on a barge and then
all sudden it trans I don't think that
like a guy like Sean doesn't know this
but I grew up at St Louis and so when
you say you're going to the casino we
actually wouldn't use the word Casino so
we would say let's go to the boat to the
boat and all the all they're not some of
them actually are like boats but a lot
of them are just like property that are
floating but they're not I guess
technically they're floating but they're
like not really a boat it's like the
boat is this like massive parking lot
and then they built like a building on
top of it but when I was younger we
would say we're g let's go to the boat
it's essentially a structure built on a
barge is really what it is but there's
no engine room it's just floating there
it's like building a house and then
shoving it out into the water and tying
it and you meet the state standards yeah
so I was talking with a buddy after I
leave fubo uh and he was showing me this
picture of his grandfather in Atlantic
City and in the background are these
Riverbats and um he said you know what
happens to these things when they're
done with them and I was like what do
you mean he goes well like where do they
go and I was like I don't know like I
have no idea and so I hang up with him
I'm like where do they go it's kind of
interesting uh I'm unemployed I don't
have much to do so uh I emailed the
general Council of a casino company that
we had done a license deal with at fubo
to get the license in Iowa uh uh and uh
uh they were a Riverboat property and I
went to it a couple times we had to go
set stuff up um and I called The General
Counsel I said hey Bill I have a
question for you your boat's really old
uh I heard you guys were thinking about
building a property on the land what are
you going to do with this cruise ship
you have sitting in front of the
property when you're done with it and he
goes well you know when you couldn't
build brick and mortar properties uh
there was a market for them you know
they'd sell because they were just
operating casinos like any other
property but he goes now no one wants
them so they kind of just end up in
junkyards and I was like you're got to
be kidding me he's like no these things
are unbelievable I go you scrap them and
he goes probably who would ever buy them
and um he just bought uh they had just
bought two casinos in Baton Rouge that
were both on vessels uh but operating
still um which they do in like places
like baton r or Kansas City and stuff
and I said are there any near us because
I'm in Chicago he's in Iowa I go are
there any near us and he goes s if there
were any boats near us I wouldn't have
bought them in Baton Rouge Louisiana and
then like almost like a movie I'm
hanging up the phone and I hear like hey
Sam Sam Sam Sam and I'm like Bill what's
up and he said we don't know where it is
uh but we think somebody somewhere in
Iowa has uh the catfish and he was
talking about Catfish Bend riverboat
casino and uh I said what do you mean
someone has he goes well they built a
property like 20 years ago and no one
knows where the boat went I'm unemployed
I'm kind of like into this kind of stuff
I have nothing to do and I was like okay
I have somewhere to be at like noon it's
like 10 o' I'm going to give myself an
hour and a half or two and try and find
this boat just for the pure fun and if
not I'll never think about this again
and we'll call it a day and so first I
called every junkyard in the tri-state
area in Chicago and Iowa I'd call uh
there was this place I remember in like
de Mo or somewhere and I and this guy
answered I'll never forget this and uh I
said hey quick question who's the oldest
guy at the junkyard who's been there the
longest and they were like on speaker
and they're all yelling like oh it's
Ricky everyone grab Ricky go get Ricky
go get and this Ricky guy gets on the
phone and this was like I've been on the
phone for an hour with junkyards and
Rick's like catfish he goes he goes I
would never forget if catfish Ben came
through this junkyard we've never seen
it so I'm like all right Ricky so I hang
up I talk to 12 Ricky this boat has not
gone to a junkyard it is not in a j and
I thought to myself if they brought it
down somewhere out of Illinois or Iowa
and it got junked in Missouri so be it I
can't call every junkyard in America but
we're going to move forward assuming
it's still still a thing so uh I found
uh I remember one time I got a ticket on
my uncle's boats and wave Runners uh in
chaino lakes and if you don't pay it it
ends up on the fishing and gaming or
like the the fishing and hunting
ticketing site so I was like all right
uh whoever is Goofy enough to buy this
thing or have it definitely got like a
moving violation or something I mean
this thing is a cruise ship it's not
like a Corolla so I said let's assume
they have a ticket and they haven't paid
it so I went to the site and I sat there
for an hour and I just clicked through
hundreds of pages of tickets but you
don't even see the pictures of anything
it's just the entity name or the
person's name and so I'm looking for
like a random entity like some kind of
sign and on like 194 page 190 something
I see like cffb whatever it is LLC it's
like an acronym and I kind of go past it
and then like I thought to myself I was
like Catfish Bend Riverboat cin I go
that kind of fits and I clicked it boom
big vessel moving violation $222,000
ticket um from the company that bought
it at auction and then I read the court
filing and
essentially catfish Ben built a brick
and mortar property left the boat to rot
kind of like icon left the casino in
Atlantic City to rot knowing that the
city would pay for it to get cleaned up
so he didn't have to pay for it they
then said all right you have to move it
we'll pay for the fees but you have to
auction it off and um so he auctioned it
off in an anonymous auction to uh a
marina construction company in Northern
Iowa who uh does a lot of work with the
Army Corps of Engineers fixing
submarines so I thought to myself o he
probably want it for the engine rooms
and stuff um but all I had was like an
entity name and it was like random and I
called a buddy in Iowa and I said hey
what do you know about this um XYZ
Enterprises or whatever and he said what
are you buying a boat and now I've been
on the phone for two hours trying to
find this thing I got like phone in the
ear I'm like notes from Ricky at the
junkyard and I was I dropped everything
I like whoa how did you know I was
talking about a boat and he said that
company he goes they fix everyone's
yachts and I was like no way so I called
like their websites from the 9s the
phone number is floating like at the
bottom of the website and I just and I
just called and I said uh hey is uh I
did what I did with the I go who's the
oldest person at this company and they
put this like 90y old man on and I said
I've got a crazy question for you and I
swear to God he cut me off and he said
tell me you're looking for the catfish
baby and I said do you have it and he
was like yeah he goes I have it I've
been looking at it every day for 20
years I said wow I said no one knows you
have this like why like no one knows
where it is and he goes yeah like you
know we're quiet like whatever and he
said why are you calling me what do you
want to buy it and I think my wife heard
in the other room and she looked at me
like you are not buying this thing and I
kind of smiled I'm like uh I don't know
maybe and he's like well why don't you
come see it and I'm like okay so long
story short I drew drove you know to
Northern Iowa and uh it was sitting
there in a quarry um he had planned to
Ed it for parts became too cost intense
to get the engines out of the engine
room and uh I persuaded myself to buy
it uh so but what's the game plan here
well okay so here's the plan um it's
first of all it's 40 it's three interior
stories all connected by elevators the
thing is a full-blown Casino vessel um
it's 40,000 square feet of some of the
most unique real estate ever when you
walk in you think you just walked into
Las Vegas with Elvis Presley the walls
the floors when I bought it all the
blackjack tables all the craps tables so
first I was like could be a movie Set uh
could I in I I know the gaming business
maybe I could open up a casino um or
maybe I'll turn it into a restaurant or
nightclub or something like that so I
had some loose ideas but nothing like in
place uh so I bought the thing um uh had
to deal with the Coast Guard all this
stuff and spent about a year going down
the path to open up a casino long story
short there's not many riverb licenses
left in America so um you know I was
meeting with the chairman of one of the
largest gaming companies in Goa India uh
he controls uh Goa which is like
Atlantic City on Western India side they
have a bunch of vessel casinos um long
story short became too cost intensive to
get it there um but he introduced me to
a deal in the uh in Southeast Asia um
where we had the deal on the one yard
line long story short uh some of these
countries in Southeast Asia are pretty
um corrupt and they made a big ask and
my lawyer said that ask is not happening
we're not talking about this anymore um
so now I'm kind of more pivoting back to
um you know partnering with someone to
open up a really cool restaurant or
entertainment venue and move it down
south somewhere like Florida or you know
Nashville Cumberland River or something
like
that what did you end up paying for
it uh I might want to tell you that off
the Pod over or under seven figures can
you say that under under okay um you
this seems like a crazy thing to to be
working on when you are able to build
websites for free or with just your time
um uh but you've done like you're you're
kind of interesting in that you can root
out these really off-the-wall ideas
because you did another one with vending
machines didn't you didn't end up doing
it but yeah so I everyone was talking
about vending machines all over Twitter
vending machines are the next gold I'm
like okay what's well we we had a guy
who like we were joking about this last
episode we had a guy who like was like
dude I'm making 15 we talk about you
know like big hundred million billion
dollar ideas and then we had this guy he
was like I'm making 10,000 a month on
vending machines and for some reason
that interests everyone because when
you're 13 years old that's like vending
machines is like one of the things that
you're fascinated by and so yeah we I
don't know if we helped to make it
popular or we pounced on it because it
was already popular but we saw that too
there's a chance I heard about it on on
the Pod I don't even know but all I know
is there was like maybe it was a year
ago or so there was like this 30-day
Rush of it was like vending machines
were like crypto or the next AI everyone
in the world wanted vending machines so
I was like all right it seems like a
terrible business so why does everyone
want this and it's like high cash flow
like I get it but similar to the ATM
business you have to go there it's
physical you have to replace product I
was like eh that can't be that
interesting but like anything else I
always go down this path of like before
I say no let me do some diligence and
I'm on like some one of those sites bis
buy sell or one of those type of sites
where you can buy a company there's this
Rural Company uh in the middle of
nowhere like Lewiston Idaho not even
Boise like Lewiston there's nothing
there and
uh it did when I I had looked at 20
companies and they all did about the
same margins whatever they were I don't
remember now this company did like three
times the margin I was like why is this
company so much better like either
they're lying and fidgeting these
numbers or something's going on and uh
the broker convinced me to go so I flew
into this like remote airport in Leon
Idaho uh and I drive 40 minutes to this
like warehouse and we open up and it is
this like full-blown operation I have
pictures I have like so many pictures of
they had hundreds and hundreds of
vending machines that they didn't even
have out there yet that they have
stocked they had more inventory you
thought they like ran a hospital there
was so much inventory and I was like
okay uh this is a bigger business than
the numbers I saw and so I said there's
no way that the numbers I read is this
business and he goes yeah they own five
regions and we listed one of them but if
it was the right person we'd probably
sell them all and I said okay and I was
trying to ask a bunch of questions and
he kept just saying like you just have
to go out with God I'm spacing out his
name um Roger or something what whoever
owned it um you just have to go out with
him and you'll know why everyone loves
vending machines I said okay so I spend
all day in Idaho in the pouring rain and
we drive around Le and Idaho and I
realize there's no grocery stores
there's no convenience stores there's no
Fox Trot coffee they rely on vending
machines it's FedEx distribution centers
it's like this is where they do build
all the turbines that go on the
propellers for the fields it's like it's
like you know the workers part of
America and everyone's lunch break they
just go to the vending machines and a
warehouse will have 50 of them snacks
cold food hot food everything they eat
is out of vending machines so I said oh
like every meal of the Working Day is
coming out of a vending machine and so
then when I dug into how the business
Works usually you're buying a contract
um from Coker Pepsi and you're you're
obligated to sell their product they
give it to you for a rate and you have
to use their machine well those are on
like five or 10 year deals so then
during diligence I asked them to give me
all of the contracts with Pepsi and Coke
because what I knew is that this local
library or this local Warehouse they
don't want to have to deal with getting
new machines they don't want to deal
with that um and so it'd be just
disruptive to the business so I realized
that all of his contracts with Coke and
Pepsi were expiring soon and I was like
well the only reason the margins aren't
absolute insanity is because I have to
pay a120 for freedos and I can only sell
them for two bucks but what if I got an
alternative to freedos and and bought it
for 4 cents and then and then sold it
for two now the margins are insane and
so I looked into like the legality of
like do I need to renew with COK or
Pepsi and the answer was no I need to
get new machines but there's companies
that'll Finance them so I was like What
if I just buy this company wait for all
the contract to expire renew none of
them and then go in without C or Pepsi
now you have a little bit of a
distribution headache because they'll
bring them to Lewis Den Idaho but Le and
Idaho there's all these like discount
stores to buy product at so it could
work and near the end of diligence uh I
had just kind of had the idea to start
my next company and I came to the
conclusion of I don't want to end up
having to move to Leon Idaho because I
bought a vending business and I need to
save it um and so while I think it's an
unbelievable opport I chose not not to
do it how big do you think that could
have been it was 5,000 machines yeah but
in dollars what what do you think it
would have done I probably would have
made like I don't know a million two a
year million three a year but it would I
I'd have to run it I felt like I was
going to have to run it for two years or
maybe a year and then hire someone but
the other thing is you're dealing with
physical stuff I need to pay drivers to
go to the things I need to have
inventory so everything had to be in
Leon and I'm like what am I gon to move
to rural Idaho so if uh that business is
doing a million a year in cash flow what
what do it sell for uh I think they
wanted four million for the business
five million so four times cash or
however they measured so I went to a
bank and and they wrote up a loan I was
going to finance it um and then I was
like wait uh what if uh I end up having
to move to Idaho this is a problem um so
so so your due diligence on these things
the reason you're fascinating is your
due diligence on these things is pretty
in depth like most people my myself
sometimes included I will endend with
like I'll just do a few Google searches
and it kind of ends there you're I mean
multiple times you're flying to places
and meet people yeah I mean I do a lot
of times within five minutes I think we
all on the back of a napkin know if a
deals make sense but I usually try and
figure out everyone else thinks there's
a a way to make this business marginally
better by consolidating and rolling them
up but how do you make it five times
better and then the answer is if there's
no answer I'm not interested um because
then I wouldn't do the deal so then I
only tried and figure out how could you
make this five times better when
everyone tries to make it 10% better and
my thought was when I looked at the line
item the biggest line item 90% of it was
the cost of goods from Coke and Pepsi I
go how can I just not sell that because
I can buy a store brand Twinkie in
wholesale for 10 times less than I have
to buy Twinkie for and so I just read
all the contracts and then I would call
people like I'd call lawyers that I knew
were in the vending business and I said
do I have to renew like here's the
language it's kind of like and they said
like there's always this like thought
from Coke or Pepsi of like you don't
really have to but they give you the
product they distribute it like it's
names that people know brands that
people know but I thought in my opinion
people's willingness to buy
Fritos uh uh wasn't that much higher
than a name brand because they have no
alternative like like right so that was
what I thought they're they're at the
job and and honestly I could also lower
the prices and those people would have
been thrilled and I talked to them I'd
go in I'd be like hey is it cool if I
like talk to your employees real quick I
was at like a distribution center and
the guys like sure just like don't take
my vending machines like that's all I
was like okay and I'd go up and I'd be
like uh hey do any of you guys care if
it wasn't Fritos anymore and then the
guy said well would it be 50 cents less
I said sure he go I don't care what it
is like Fritos are Fritos and I was like
huh interesting so that's where I think
the value in vending is if you're not
just trying to build like some big cap
like like I just wouldn't buy a vending
route or an ATM route or anything like
that to just try to improve it because
I'm a better operator like I think
people think they're sub like you can be
the best operator in the world but the
business is the business so um that's
kind of how I look at those things well
I love that you um go down these R
random rabbit holes so Riverboat
gambling um vending machines I'm sure
you've done more than we've just talked
about in terms of thinking about ideas
you you seem like you're one of us you
have that switch it can't turn off and
so regardless of what you're doing
you're always GNA be thinking of of
ideas or you're gonna hear something
it's gonna make you curious and
interested and you say well maybe not
for me but that for somebody that would
be actually pretty interesting uh do you
have a couple of ideas you could share
that maybe somebody in the audience
might get uh get inspired by what are
the other ideas the silver Bal ideas
things that you're not necessarily doing
um or you're just willing to share
um there was another business that would
actually be a lot in my opinion a lot
easier than the vending business in
Idaho um I was at uh about two summers
ago um a lot of my friends you know they
went to missou so we'll go to Lake of
the Ozarks in the summer Fourth of July
or something like that and the redneck
Rivier
baby home of the uh home of the uh the
the wet t-shirt contest and and lost
GoPros at the bottom of uh at the bottom
of 40t of water that's actually a good
business Sean um if you if you want to
hire divers there's probably millions of
dollars of GoPros at the bottom of Lake
of the
ozar so I'm at Lake of the ozar darks
and I hadn't been since I had left
college so it had been a couple years
and we needed to get from our Airbnb to
and I'm sure Sam knows this place the
place called Shady Gators it is it is it
is the uh Sean if you looked up on
Google Shady Gators uh I think you would
tell me you're not going is what you
would say um it's like classic spring
break it say it says College spring
break bikini wet t-shirt contest as a
gets and unfortunately the bridge at
Lake of the Ozarks is on like the far
side from where our Airbnb was and the
only way to get there is to drive all
the way around the lake well that's like
a 50-minute uber and instead of that
they have water taxis and I didn't even
know about this my buddy's like yeah
just call a dispatcher like they'll send
a a water taxi what am I in Venice I was
like okay so uh we we call this guy and
like seven seconds later he pulls up to
our Airbnb in the water and we just get
on and all my buddies were drinking
we're on their way there and all I can
think about is how how much is this guy
making right now and I said to my buddy
I said how much are we paying him I
whispered and he's like it's 250 we
split it between the five of us I go I'm
sorry this is like a three minute ride
three minutes tops and I go and he just
goes around and so I couldn't help
myself I asked him I said hey um do you
like own this thing and you could tell
he like he was driving it but he did own
it but he wanted he didn't want people
to realize that the owner was driving he
wanted to feel like it was a company he
has the brand on the boat like all this
stuff and he was like yeah we own it
yeah he said we he said we he said we uh
and uh so all my buddies are like
getting off and they're running in the
Shady Gators uh and I am just locked on
this guy I go hold on a second hold on a
second I was like it's $250 it took 90
seconds to get us here and he's like
he's like yeah it's seasonal because it
gets cold here in the winter but he's
like we spew cash All Summer in spring
and summer I said what does spew cash
mean exactly and he said well I have
three boats um and he goes all I do is I
have a dispatcher and she sits behind a
monitor and has like a live feed because
they have like some they put like a
drone up there with some things so she
can see where all the boats are and she
has the GPS and when people call she can
see their IP address because when you
call into the dispatcher it's like some
platform that shows you so they know
where people are on the lake and then
she'll load it into their thing on the
boat to go where to go next and a lot of
these boats have like GPS so you just
click accept just like you do on Uber
and they drive around and I'm like okay
uh and I said to him I said uh would you
ever like raise capital for this
business or like do you need more
like uh are there more people than you
can get and he said by 10 12 well how
much was he making oh like like every
boat made him like about 400 Grand a
summer he had three of them so he was
doing like a million to yeah and he's
and he's from you know you know he built
this from nothing started with one boat
used the money to buy another boat but
he doesn't know how to like he's not he
didn't he would wait too long because he
didn't know you could just like Go
finance a boat he would just wait till
he could pay 90 grand cash for a speed
boat it's like you can just put down n
Grand like a car and you'd have 10
tomorrow so but he didn't know how to do
any of these things so I said if you had
money um and you had 20 boats would it
be too many boats and now they're
sitting around he goes I could probably
fill 10 boats as much as I fill these
three but I don't want to spend the cash
I kind of use it to you know I bought a
house we built a lake house like all
this stuff and so then I was like okay
that's that that's that precious
Mountain Dew money baby so then I'm like
okay what if I this is also post buying
the Riverboat before my next company so
I'm still in like the vending mode of
like can I blow up a business like this
and so I called him because we were
talking about maybe I would invest in
the company and I said uh hey Connor uh
I changed my mind uh would you sell me
this business and he was like sell you
this business I was like yeah he goes I
never thought about that like I don't
know what it's worth or anything um and
my thought process was what if I can
blow this up to 10 or 15 boats on Lake
of the Ozarks and then go to Orange
Beach Alabama and then go and then start
going around America and building up the
water taxi business Baton Rouge
Louisiana you need to get from Tiger
Stadium to you know Fred's bar whatever
it is and then water is the only
vertical that Uber doesn't have and lft
doesn't have and then I called people
Executives those companies and they said
it's so difficult it's so Regional the
weather all this stuff we don't want to
own boats we have to dock them all this
stuff but they kind of made a comment
like but we'd buy it if it existed but
we won't build that so I said okay so
now I have a willing buyer of this
business um so I thought if I could do
this um uh he was taking most of the
cash for himself I would buy this
business I don't need any of the money
so I would take all the money and just
buy more boats until I've maximized Lake
of the Ozarks and then I would go you
know Lake Town by Lake town and uh lot
of liability lot of logistical things
definitely think it's worth doing but it
didn't I ran all the numbers I tried to
estimate forecast out what I thought
this business could do and I just I had
decided when I left fubo that the next
thing I was going to do I had no
interest in if it couldn't be worth at
least a billion dollars in five years
and I thought if it could be it was the
absolute ceiling and you'd have to
execute perfectly and hope there's no
legal issues and weather and damage and
like all it's a very physical business
so I chose not to do it but I think it's
a big opportunity and I think we'll see
Uber buy some water taxi company in like
20 28 I think we'll see that can I just
read you the menu of shady Gators would
you guys be interested in that yeah be
very interested tell me all the
variations of tater tots you mean Gator
bites or ultimate tater tots or loaded
loaded tots um for me I'm gonna start
with the shrimp happens that's where I'm
gonna start uh Sam for my friend Sam he
wants the Brazilian Sizzle those are
the I this place looks phenomenal this
place looks like I think
you're focused on the boats you needed
to buy Shady Gators uh this is an
institution you know like you know when
rich people go buy like the Washington
Post this could have been your washow
you know you could have bought Shady
Gators and been like I will protect this
this uh this National treasury Shady
Gators will cash flow for hundreds of
years to come as long as there's boobs
and there's white shirts this place will
stay
upright we we have to take sea Sean's
never been to some of these places we
got to take him on a tour to florama
down in uh yeah there's this restaurant
Sean it's called florama they even made
a TV show about it it was like the I've
seen that so I've seen these all through
the TV safely while I'm you know under a
blank for years that's where that's
where I spent spring break florama is
right at the the Alabama Florida line
there's literally a line like in the
ground and this restaurant is half on
each side and it's where you go for just
pure debauchery when you are 21 years
old old or 19 with a fake ID these
places are wild you have to experience a
good four B I had a buddy from New York
who when I bought the vessel uh it's in
like rural Iowa and uh he flew into this
private airport because he had to see
this thing and he had never been to he's
we're like running out of gas on the
highway and he's like we have to pull
over we have to pull over he's like
flipping out and I'm like we're good man
there's a gas station in eight miles and
we have like a reserve tank like don't
worry about it like he's used to New
York UBS and like just getting in Uber
blacks and like being in the middle of
nowhere Iowa he was like panicking he's
taking pictures of like gas stations he
thinks they're like he thinks they're
like uh
monuments it's like a safari for him
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is where people
get gas Brian yeah so um so you know
what I wish I kind of wish there was
a well in general I'll say this you're
like we have the segment on this pod
called the Blue Collar side hustle
you're like the walking Blue Collar side
hustle right like all of these ideas
you're talking about are so Middle
America I love it and they are so um
just uh you know hustle and Ingenuity
that I love it and you're finding really
interesting opportunities that are off
the beaten path right it's like you want
to do things that the 99 like if you if
you say all right I'm not the smartest
guy there is maybe I'm in the I'm in the
top 20% of IQ what you want is within
that top 20% you want to then go look in
places where 99% of them them don't look
CU now you're you know you're operating
in a field of your own and it seems like
that's what you're doing I kind of wish
this existed um Nationwide because what
what you're finding is you're finding a
bunch of opportunities that you know how
you would execute them but now they're
no longer worth your time or the the the
schlep that you would have to eat to do
it you were willing to do it with your
first business but now on your third
business you're not as willing to do
that um you know T Peter teal did this
thing called the teal Fellowship where
he was like I'm going to pay kids to
drop out of college if they're
exceptional and they might create big
things and out of that came you know
figma and ethereum and some of the like
kind of breakthrough multi-billion
dollar tech companies I kind of feel
like there should be a blue collar teal
Fellowship where we just go and we we we
post a flyer in a bunch of campuses that
just says um sick of this drop out
and make millions and let's just see who
shows up and it's going to be the person
who's like this is probably but
like I'm down what else am I going to do
go to organic chemistry right now like I
got to see what's here there's going to
be like eight people at the seminar and
of the eight you know five will leave
halfway through because they think it's
a time share presentation and out of the
three remaining there'll be one person
who's like oh you're telling me that
you'll help me go find a business within
a mile and a half of this campus right
now that if I just like Focus for three
years can make me $9
million all right I'm in I'm I'm sitting
I already go to you know Boise State or
I already you know like at where I went
to school at Duke there was this one bar
it was our version of shady Gators
called Shooters and if anybody went and
bought Shooters it's like guess what sir
you now have a monopoly on The Nightlife
scene of Durham and every single student
will come there and like this place just
hasn't changed and like look if if the
mechanical bull just took Apple pay your
Revenue would go up 10 per. like there's
just a bunch of easy wins that can be
had just by like thinking about things
slightly differently you know the
example I would give of Shooters would
be cool during the day this needs to be
essentially like a yoga studio and at
night it's going to become the nightclub
and now you're going to go from you know
10% usage to maybe 45% usage and that
will be a big that's how you do your
your 5x um I feel like that needs to
exist I feel like we need to find the
Sam raters that are out there they're
out there right now in every college and
they just need a little bit of inspo a
little bit of ideas and and a little bit
of mentorship in order to do yeah the
problem with the businesses I found is
that if the value is in the fact that
it's remotely located well then it's
difficult because other than finding
another Lewis in Idaho that already has
an operating business and has those
Dynamics if the town relies on it you
can't scale it out of Leon on but the
reason I love the water taxi thing is
because there's 10 or 12 great water
lake towns in America so I liked that a
little bit better but my concern was
when I really forecasted it out it'd be
a big win but it would take it would
take five to seven years and I was like
nope just just not willing just just
couldn't yeah so that that's always the
problem but for someone who has I don't
know I don't want to
say for someone who is only pure want to
execute and wants to retire and have 20
30 $40 million I think that's a great
play well for a lot of people that's
that's not necessarily where you have to
retire but it's like when you're at
zero $7 million sounds like all the
dollars and uh and then once you have $7
million and you're now 24 and your
friends are you know still paying off
student debt and you're sitting there
being like I learned so much and I have
Financial Freedom I can do whatever I
want they can do the thing you did and
go chase down this River for you know 9
months where other people wouldn't
wouldn't think to go do that right so
it's it's a it's a gateway drug into
doing you know more and more interesting
things what were the other Investments
you said you made two Investments that
were awesome I assume one of them was
the the boat yeah um I've invested not a
lot because I really am focused on what
I'm doing but I have made some private
investments into startups that I try to
be as helpful with as I can you said
that you want to start something that
can get to a billion in I assume you met
exit value in 5 years you have a new
company now is that the one that you
think going to do it so showroom so when
I was at um fubo TV uh when I left we
were doing about a billion dollars a
year in
Revenue don't quote me they're public we
can find the numbers I think about 700
million was the monthly subscriptions to
fubo TV so $59.99 if you buy Red Zone
you're probably near 100 bucks whatever
it was uh and then 300 million uh give
or take was the advertising which is
when you scale a streaming business it's
the whole business so I thought to
myself why are these companies coming to
fubo TV we're big but we're not massive
uh so there's got to be a play here that
they think there's value here um and
what I realized is traditional cable
Nationwide too expensive Disney plus
ESPN plus and Hulu um all owned by
Disney um kind of at a scale where
pricing is probably similar to being
National um and we were small enough
that if you wanted six zip codes in
Nashville uh we'd give it to you um and
so what clearly the sentiment was from
these companies was that uh it's very
hard to get in front of consumers uh
Google shopping uh while is okay for a
user is unusable for a merchant because
no one's outbidding calv inclin for the
word underwear or black denim jacket
it's become way too corporate I think
like 80% or maybe 70% of the brands that
buy keywords for E for fashion Footwear
on Google shopping I think in their last
report
I think it was like one of like a few
hundred Brands and there's tens of
thousands of Brands so most of them AR
on there and I was in a meeting once
with the former C CMO of like a direct
to Consumer cowboy boot brand and uh she
made this interesting comment in a
meeting and she was like yeah we waste
like 50 cents of every dollar we spend
on Google and I was like whoa whoa whoa
hold on a second excuse me like stop the
meeting that's craziest thing I've ever
heard I go why is that and she said
because we pay about $4 to own the word
cowboy boots and half the time someone
looks up cowboy boots it's a third
grader looking up cowboy boots for their
third grade presentation they need a
photo to like cut out and put on their
poster they had no intent of buying $700
boots so we waste 50 cents of every
dollar and I was like whoa whoa whoa
whoa and she said this is the first time
I heard this concept she said that's why
Vertical Search is so great I said what
do you mean and she had been an
executive uh she was a c or I don't know
if she was a CMO very senior at cars.com
and she said people look up Toyota on
Google for all kinds of reasons photos
videos they might be looking at Toyota's
stock price but if they look up at
Toyota and cars.com they're a buyer or
they're a seller there's High intent
you're not just browsing around cars.com
so I said that's interesting so then I
was like okay so those are really
Google's competitors is all these
vertical places to find what you want to
find that has a better experience and
more tailor than just traditional search
so I essentially uh do what I always try
to do like in the vending business I
called the lawyers who know the Pepsi
contracts I called as many Engineers on
the Google shopping team is I could get
to agreed to talk to me um and the
sentiment was they said Sam we want
Google flights to be a really great
experience for Google users but not at
the detriment of stepping on the toes of
our large largest advertisers Expedia
kayak they want them to pay and they
want them to battle it out they don't
think it's not a good business to be in
they would just rather them battle it
out and battle it out means pay Google
to be there and my conclusion was okay
could this be done better now and I was
very anti- crypto still am don't like
crypto at all never never boned it um
and so when all this AI started coming
out I had this initial sentiment of like
Eh this is crypto again I don't believe
in this I have changed my mind on that
um and what I realized I was like if I
showed you two black t-shirts and one's
from Lululemon and ones from Gap if we
remove the brand names the product
descriptions the actual copy is
shockingly similar it's just describing
a black T-shirt um it's really inherent
in the sentiment of the brand as to what
that shirt is for Lulu's shirt is for
one thing Gap shirt could be an
undershirt and so um your inability to
have like a ongoing conversation with a
language model that knows every brand
and product in the world um would be
very limiting and you'd end up with
Google shopping so what we've done is uh
we've built this huge infrastructure we
have thousands and thousands of
merchants tens of millions of SKS um
that kind of organically come into this
data set we've trained a language model
to understand nothing besides what's in
that data set and then that can
communicate um to a user so they can
have an ongoing conversation with
essentially think about like not just
Neiman Marcus or not just Macy's or not
just a retailer who picked a couple
hundred Brands to carry but you can
essentially communicate back and forth
with an inventory of every brand in the
world and the reason why shopping's
always had these big opportunities is
because everything else has been
dominated by Amazon or Alibaba and they
have their market share in the like
cheap fast fashioned sector but Gucci's
not on Amazon burberry's not on Amazon
every brand at Neiman Marcus toova away
luggage these companies like they might
people might sell Nike products on
Amazon Nike is not on Amazon so that's
why companies like shop Runner had come
along where they're like we're going to
be the Amazon Prime for everything
Amazon doesn't have and they scaled and
sold to FedEx for hundreds of millions
the founders on our board at showroom so
there's always been these opportunities
in fashion for product Discovery and I
actually think prior to language models
this is this is absolutely a business
that would have been very very hard to
build because you lack that brand
sentiment um and so that's essentially
what we've built we're launching the
beta here shortly we have thousands of
people on the waiting waiting list we're
really excited we have Revenue share
deals with every single Merchant in the
platform those Revenue share deals
fluctuate you know between five and 20%
just depending on the brand you know
Nike pays you you know a point probably
but you know a a director consumer brand
is paying for growth they'll pay you a
15% Revenue share all day you're kind of
doing what you did before where the with
the betting site you're like well the
consumers went this and I don't know if
I can differentiate that and so you went
to the brand side you know if a if a
Marketplace has two sides you went to
the brand side you're sort of doing that
with with this where you're like
thinking well what's the problem for
advertisers but it seems like with these
consumer products the hardest part is
getting the consumers and once you have
them often times you can figure out not
or I don't know if often is the right
word some of the times you can figure
out how do you monetize a huge audience
aren't are are you scared that you're
not going to be able to figure out how
to get the actual users there no because
I think inherent in the platform is the
transaction so then there's transaction
fees the merchants pay Revenue shares if
you're a consumer platform for like
entertainment
social entertainment's become a little
bit of a commodity that's why Netflix
does these originals but everyone else
like fubo Hulu ESPN Disney we all just
had ESPN and TNT and everyone has the
same stuff and if you're social you have
to increase engagement but if you are
something where there's transactions
well now inherent in the experience is
transacting and that's where you can
make money so that's why I think
companies
like the social the ones that get a big
audience and then go social I think it's
a huge mistake like Pinterest big
audience and then they went like social
not Commerce um and to me it's like well
no one Minds paying fees or having
hidden fees into things that they were
already buying people might complain
about fees on Airbnb but they were
already booking something and so I think
the value is can you build a big
consumer business then inherent in the
journey is a transaction and your
product is a 100 times better shopping
experience than what they had before so
I always just lean on focus on the
consumer forget everything else if the
consumer wants it everything else is
noise you can push it through and
consumers will want the product so I
want to ask you about the way your brain
works because I find you very
interesting and we always ask everybody
before they come on what are some of
your strong opinions or life
philosophies that you would you you live
by and you gave us a couple but I want
you to explain them so uh number One
never ever pitched twice what is that so
every investor I've ever had the moment
I pitched them and walked out of the
room called me 12 times showed up at my
door in Chicago and said I won in this
round um same thing with employees
everyone I've ever you know I'm always
recruiting anyone who's ever wanted to
join the company the moment they wanted
to join the company they wanted to drop
everything they were doing to join the
company in my opinion raising capital is
an informative process not a persuasive
one within 5 minutes of us getting on
the call today I think we all we had
some preconceived notions of what we
thought of each other and then within 5
minutes I'd say you'd have a 90%
cemented view of what you think of the
person and so when I'm pitching um I'm
going in and I'm giving them my full
attention but I'm informing them of what
we're building and what we're doing um
and it's one thing if they have
legitimate diligence questions as
follow-ups or whatever but I never ask
twice because I know that everyone who's
ever really wanted to do it didn't need
to be asked twice they loved it and so I
would rather just move on to the next
one um and in my opinion you give them
the information they've formed their
opinions if you're ever trying to
persuade them you're on the wrong side
of the table from a negotiation
standpoint anyways um and so I just
don't pitch twice um I try to be as
cognizant if I can that you always want
to be respectful of like Venture
Associates at the fun because sometimes
by pure volume if it's like a big fun
like a sequoia they their principles
can't take every meeting they need some
layers that's fine um and if they have
legit follow- on questions I'll get back
on more calls and answer emails whatever
but I never pitch twice because I know
that if I need to kind of sell it again
then they didn't want it and that
doesn't mean that you can't have luck
following up and being ruthless about
the followup and you there's those
stories where you push it through but
there's thousands of funds in my opinion
capital's pretty cheap if you have a
great business you're going to raise the
money and so I kind of just move on to
people that are so excited by it that
they are willing to get on a phone on
Christmas um because they know this
could be a life-changing opportunity for
them you know so that's kind of how I
view pitching you've got this other one
that is um I don't know if controversial
is the right word but it's kind a lot of
people wouldn't agree so you said the
but the potential you see in others is
not real it's rarely potential realize
so take everyone at face value for what
they are today well there's one one key
line in there is that you said it's a
mirror of what you would do if you were
in their
position I've thought about I always
have like these I have like a massive
massive list on my phone and I have
these Concepts and and I have another
notepad of Concepts that I haven't
really figured out a way to explain it
the right way I always try to boil down
this thought I have to like two
sentences and recently on Twitter I saw
someone say this which is the potential
I don't know who it was but the
potential you see in others is rarely
realized it's simply a mirror of what
you would do if you were them I have
spent a lot of time in my life trying to
I don't want to say change other people
but I I think they have such great
potential
but I always feel like it's like you're
dragging a bag of bricks in your
backpack to the office it's like they
just if they don't want it on their own
you just can't change them and what I
see in them is really what I would do if
I were them but it's not what they want
to do and so I'm not saying you can't
put in effort to coach people up and
make them great members of the team but
that's different than if they want to be
there or not if they don't want to be
there you know if they don't want to box
they're not showing up to the gym and
boxing for 12 hours a day to go beat
Floyd Mayweather they don't want to be
there and so if you think they're a
great boxer and they show up every day
okay you can coach them but I just feel
like it's a wasted effort and you should
take people for exactly what they are
and what do what do those people love
doing more than anything as much as I
love running businesses and building
businesses and doing things like this
what do they love as much as I love this
and can I get that task to be something
in my business because then they're
going to do great but if it's anything
other than that they're just better off
going to somewhere else where they want
want that skill set and so I just think
that you should pretty quickly know it's
like if you're a trainer or you're a
coach does the player want to be there
and if they don't want to be there you
can be mad that like ah they're 6 eight
it's like in high school when your coach
goes to the volleyball team they're like
Peter like stop spiking volleyballs like
you could play center you know at Duke
and they're like he I like volleyball he
just likes volleyball and anytime
they've ever gotten that kid to say fine
I'll play on the basketball team he
doesn't care he doesn't want to come to
practice he's never very good and just
don't realize the potential but his
potential while it looked to you if you
were 68 on the volleyball team you could
be a great basketball player Peter
doesn't want to be a great basketball
player so it just doesn't work out so
that's kind of like my opinion on that
that kind of
stuff let's do one more you have one on
here that I'm curious about it says uh
the value is in the duck calls it's a
good one and uh I think that's the
perfect one to end on here what does
that mean me and um who's um best man at
my wedding Jonah Roberts uh I'll give
him a shout out Jonah uh he's from
Memphis sound like he almost forgot his
name Jonah and I were no no definitely
didn't remember his name um Jonah and I
were in Memphis Tennessee uh in his
hometown and he wanted to take me to the
Bass Pro Shop which there is like the
Holy Growl um and we're walking around
which feels like ours and we cannot stop
dying laughing every single aisle every
product you could ever imagine you need
for hunting and fishing and home tools
they have everything and uh right when
we think we've seen every product that
anyone's ever made we stumble to come
around the corner to go to the like
where the back of the store is and
there's this big almost like when you go
to a guitar store and they put all the
expensive ones in a room there's this
sign that says duck calls and there's
like this glass door and we open and
there's like what felt like a 100,000
duck calls they've got metal duck calls
polyester duck calls they've got Stone
duck calls they've got duck calls with
two heads they have different colors
they have it's like this whole economy
of duck calls that we didn't even know
existed and so what I realized is the
reason I dig in to the vending
businesses in the riverboats and the
water taxis is because the value is in
the duck calls the value is in the
things that no one knows about that are
very odd that have these Niche
ecosystems of communities and the people
who love duck calls trust me they love
duck calls they'll pay a thousand
dollars for a duck call they don't go
hunting for they don't go without them
it's like a big thing they collect them
and it's something I never knew about
and so whenever I hear about something
that could be really big and then I hear
a bunch of people I go I go I've never
heard of that like who would ever want
that and then I go on like one random
Brands site in the duck call business
and some random Merchant I've never
heard before has 800,000 followers and
does $5 million a year that like cements
to me that all the values in the duck
calls it's in the things that people
don't know about or are too complicated
to find or our regional or our Niche or
one of those things so I always kind of
me and Jonah always kind of say the
value is in the duck calls I I have a
feeling Sam well first of all are you
going to call your shot now so your new
business um are you are are you going to
call your shot where in five years
you're gonna it's gonna be worth a
billion dollars because what I want to
look back in five years because I think
you're good you've clearly have the it
Factor some you've already done amazing
things but something more amazing I
predict is gonna happen with you I don't
know when but is this going to be the
one you think I do are you gonna hit
your fiveyear goal how your a year into
it I bet uh yeah I would say that would
be the goal would I wouldn't I would not
work on
every day I wake up it's like every day
you own a building you own a stock
you're choosing to buy it and every day
I choose to work on this I think more
and more uh that is definitely going to
work and the moment that I think it's
going the other way I will not work on
it so we're going to look back on this
December
2028 and we're going to see if you if
you nailed it but I have a feeling
you're going to do something amazing and
uh we appreciate you coming on man
you're you're awesome no thanks for
having me I've been following the Pod
since you started in 19 when I was I I
used to watch your videos out of the
lifetime yoga studio
that's amazing uh awesome man thank you
for coming on you're you're fun all
right we appreciate you and that's a
[Music]
pop